الحمد لله قد صمت شهرين متتابعين توبه الى
الله ان يكون تسببت في موت او ضرر اي احد
من ابناء هذا الشعب العزيز اعلنوا توبتهم
عن ذنب اقترفوه للسماح باللقاحات سابقا
وما هي الا ايام وقد تسببوا بوفاه عشرات
الاطفال حرموا في مناطق سيطرتهم من
التحصين ضد شلل الاطفال تطورات سريعه
لحملات حوثيه مستعره اعادت اليمن سنوات
الى الخلف بعد ان اعلنت قبل انقلاب
الحوثيين خلوها من شلل الاطفال معطيات
دفعت الحكومه الى المصارعه في تدشين حمله
تطعيم واسعه للاطفال في المناطق المحرره
مع رصد عشرات الاصابات بشلل الاطفال قادمه
من مناطق سيطره الحوثيين
الحوثيين ليسوا من اليوم ضد اللقاءات
ولكنهم منهم بداوا حربهم في صعدهم ضد
اللقاحات وضد التطعيم في محافظه صعده
والان اغلب الحالات المصابه ظهرت
محافظه صعده من النازحين في محافظه صعده
الى مارب كذلك اغلب الحالات التي ظهرت
الان من المناطق التي تحتت لها الحوثين
والتي يمنعون فيها تلقيح وتطعيم الاطفال
عشرات الفرق الطبيه الثابته والمتنقله
بدات عمليه التطعيم منذ امس الاحد
بالتزامن مع توسع حملات التوعيه الاعلاميه
بضروره حمايه الاطفال وتحصينهم من الشلل
تحرك وجده تفاعلا مجتمعيا واسعا في مارب
وغيرها من المحافظات
وعزز هذا التفاعل الخوف من تفشي حالات
الشلل مع تواتر الاخبار عن ضحاياه في
مناطق سيطره الحوثيين
اتخلص من مرض ان شاء الله الاطفاء وكان
المرض قد انتهى وعندما حدين منعوا تطعيم
ضد شلاطف فظهر تم مشكله من جديد وظهرت
حاله وفاه
نجلاء يكون بصحتهم يت
وهيكون بصحه جيده تعود الامراض الفيروسيه
والاوبئه التي اعلن اليمن خلوه منها عام
2006 الى الواجهه وتتبخر كل الجهود التي
بذلت على مدى عقود بسبب ممارسات لشيات
الحوثي والقناعات المزيفه التي تحاول
نشرها ويكتوي باثارها المدمره اطفال اليمن
محمود الحميدي العربيه مارب